[Music]
I feel loved on and I feel used my body
makes me feel the way you do and
sometimes I sometimes I sometimes I just
can't stand it
isn't that just a thing about us I'm
still thinking you could be the one but
you're always you're always you're
always taking me for granted
I got something I gotta get off of my
chest
I've been staying up while you're
sleeping in my bed
I don't hate you babe it's worse than
that cause you heard me and I don't
react I've been building up
this thing for months oh
man
you say you know me like you know
yourself
but there's a part of you that you can't
help and you say you can't do it just do
it just do it for my sake
a shame knowing we could be good
you could treat me better if you really
wanted to and if you can't do it for my
sake do it for our sake
I don't hate you baby
it's worse
[Music]
I've been building up this thing for
months oh
[Music]
oh I don't know how to leave or how to
stay
so I've been talking to strangers cause
I can't talk to you anymore though it
and I'll let you down cause you let me
down you would never say that you let me
down but you let me down and you let me
down
foreign
[Music]
cause you heard me and I'm more than
said I've been building up
this thing for months
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks
that felt really good